good afternoon everyone
thank you for taking time to join us in
today's webinar take out
a call for sustainable take away
innovations my name is judea
and i'm from designing singapore council
i will be your event emcee and moderator
for today
today's session is actually brought to
you by design singapore council
and supported by jtc rens and your group
limited
and this webinar is part of our series
of engagement and sharing sessions
under the good design research
initiative and this initiative
actually aims to help our singaporean
designers and design enterprises
find their unique value proposition in
designing for impact
through research and experimentation
along with our network of knowledge
partners like the speakers we have today
so before we proceed i would just like
to highlight a few housekeeping rules
firstly feel free to reach out to our
technical team
through the zoom chat function below if
you encounter any technical issues
and secondly if you have any queries
along the way you can also use the q
a function below um as your audio will
be on mute
throughout remember that when posing a
question
please state your name and company
company and also indicate
if you have a specific panelist whom
you'd like to direct your question to
so with that please allow me to
introduce our speakers for today in this
afternoon's program
my colleague kwemi will also be joining
us shortly to share an overview of the
good design research initiative i
mentioned earlier
which we will refer to as gdr from here
on and
next up we will also have three speakers
sharing on the challenge statements on
designing sustainable food packaging and
innovative processes
the first speaker we have is grace young
who is an assistant director of the
lifestyle department of the food and
lifestyle cluster at jtc
so jcc is the lead government agency
campaigning for sustainable
industrial development in singapore our
second speaker we have winnie lou
who is who hates the marketing team in
rens
as a senior marketing manager our ens is
a multi-concept owner
and operator of more than 70 fmb outlets
in singapore
and malaysia as well providing customers
with authentic
japanese dining experiences last but not
least we also have t
au tan who currently leads the sales
team and at orange club
and she also caters a brand under the
new group limiter
finally we will end the session with a q
a segment
as well as i'm sharing more information
about design singapore council's
upcoming gdr open call this month and
this is where
you can submit an application if you are
keen to respond to rens
on your group limited challenge
statements which will be presented
in a short while so without further ado
we will start this session with an
introduction to the gdr initiative by
haimi
please hey trudeau
thank you for the quick introduction and
thank you all for taking the time to
join us today
so i'm not sure how many of you would
have heard about the gdr initiative but
if you haven't i would like to make a
quick introduction to the initiative
so firstly i'll be sharing on why the
good design research initiative
is important and then secondly on the
key elements
of this initiative so its importance in
today's context was very apparent when
we conducted our
research in close consultation with our
designers
and design enterprises we interviewed
many of them with most of them also
recognizing that design
for impact which is also what most of
them will recognize as good design will
help them shape their unique value
proposition
and help them to stand out in the global
marketplace and then on the demand side
there has always been a recognition on
the role that design
can play in mitigating the world's
complex issues
this is especially apparent i think when
we all experience the covet pandemic
about how you know the design innovation
that we need right now goes beyond
simply just you know
improving user experiences for personal
care but
and also like fmb but also
research that requires i mean design
research that is
deep as well so clearly there's a need
for deep research that is fundamental
to good design so for good design
research we realize as we engaged
our stakeholders is that you know it
requires two key things
right a significant investment as well
as a strong network that is not always
possible with um smaller design firms
and therefore with the good design
research initiative the
the design singapore council plans to
bridge these two resource gaps
first uh we aim to build a strong
network
of knowledge and resource partners as
well as impact driven clients to foster
collaborations that is necessary for
multi-disciplinary
projects for example we have been
inviting impact driven speakers with
challenge statements that designers may
respond to
so in this webinar we have rens as well
as new group sharing this
we have also featured in our last few
webinars you know experts in the field
of technology
systems and processes or identity and
culture
those with concepts and tools
that they could share with our designers
and that our designers can tap
on moving forward we will also be
sharing more of these resources on our
website as well as social media
channels so these are potential resource
partners that designers can tap on
to leverage on for their projects and
then the second part of the good design
research initiative
uh aims to support the exploratory
projects through open calls so we have
an upcoming open call
in march and that if you are keen to
respond to renss as well as new groups
uh challenge statements that they will
be sharing
later on you may submit a proposal
through our upcoming open call
this month and then you may also stand a
chance to receive
sponsorship mentorship as well as
publicity support
if your project is selected so through
these two key phases
the good design research initiative
encourages designers to develop unique
value propositions
in particular it seeks to support
designers embarking on projects with
deep exploration and research into these
three tracks that you see here
on the left identity and culture systems
and processes as well as new technology
as well as projects that has a focus on
design impact so i think i hope that
this
brief overview gives you a rough idea of
what the good design research initiative
is all about
we'll be sharing with you a qr code at
the end of the session if you would like
to know more information about this
initiative
so with this i'll pass the time back to
julia
thank you thanks weimi right now we'll
invite grace from jtc to introduce the
challenge statement
um on designing sustainable food
packaging and innovative processes
all right over to you race okay
thank you hi everyone welcome to the
webinar and thank you so much for your
interest in the first joint open call
organized by psg and gtc
my name is grace and today i'm here to
give you some background and also an
overview of today's challenge statement
so let me first start by giving you an
introduction on jtc
um so for those who aren't familiar with
us jtc is a secretary bought under the
ministry of trade
industries so our role is to support new
industries and also existing enterprises
by
planning promoting and developing
industrial infrastructure in singapore
as an industrial infrastructure
specialist we have
developed a total of 8 200 hectares of
industrial land
and we manage close to 100 industrial
assets in singapore which i believe most
of you might have come across
these include our business parks like
one north at buena vista
uh cleantech park beside ngu we also
have indus uh generic estates like
swaying huddle in the north and royal
middle east
and also specialized estates like
servita aerospace park
and trust biomedical park we are also
currently developing next
uh generation estates like the jerome
innovation district and hong kong
digital district
so do stay tuned for exciting things
coming up like these two essays in the
coming years
so having so much land also means that
we also have a large
customer profile we currently serve more
than 13 000 business customers across
various industry sectors
such as advanced manufacturing
aerospace clinicals and logistics
so this large network of industrialists
and companies under our care
we saw an opportunity to actually bring
these
companies together to do something so in
uh
in january last year we launched an
initiative called the gdc industry
connect
and through this initiative we hope to
support business growth by forming
collaborative partnerships within our
business network so
we also bring in any less academia
government agencies to look at five key
areas
namely in business foundation talent
development
technology adoption supply chain
optimization and also
environmental sustainability which is
our focus today
so as part of the industry connect
platform we have reached out to design
singapore council on the good design
research initiative to explore
collaboration or sustainable packaging
so i'll now go into some background on
why we picked this topic as the key
focus
of our collaboration
our initiative is in support of
singapore's inaugural
zero waste master plan which maps out
singapore's key strategies to build a
sustainable
resource efficient and climate resilient
nation
the amount of waste disposal in
singapore has increased sevenfold over
the last 40 years
and at this rate samakal landfill which
is our only landfill would run out of
space by 2035
so the master plan has set up a new
waste reduction target for singapore
which is to reduce the amount of waste
sent to samakal
each day by thirty percent by twenty
thirty
so this will help to extend samaka
lentils lifespan beyond twenty thirty
five
and uh measures to reduce waste will
include adopting a circular
economy approach to waste and resource
management practices
and also shifting towards more
sustainable production and
consumption
there are some strategies that the
master plan has mapped out to steer
industries towards indus sasebo
production these
include looking into more sustainable
designs for products uh
identifying opportunities for resource
efficiency
and also promoting industries and biosis
so today's focus
is actually on sustainable design which
is to design products to be more durable
and repairable to lengthen their
lifespan and delay their entry into the
waste room
and we could also create them with
materials and components that
could be taken apart easily so that it
can be easier
it can be easier to recycle
one of the key priority waste streams
identified in the zero-based master plan
is packaging waste
and packaging waste including plastic
makes up of
one-third of domestic waste disposed of
in singapore so we do see importance in
focusing our efforts in closing the
resource loop for packaging waste to
help singapore achieve its goal towards
beginning
becoming zero of the waste nation
in 2019 mandatory packaging reporting
was scattered under the resource
stressing ability act
and this is the first step towards more
sustainable packaging waste management
and it lays the foundation of the
extended producer responsibility
framework for managing
packaging waste which naa is targeting
to have in place
by 2025 and as part of the
npr requirements companies will need to
submit 3r plans
that include kpis and targets of the key
initiatives on how we will reduce
we use or recycle packaging companies
will also be required to report on the
progress of their plans in the
subsequent years of the reporting
so there are various types of pr plans
listed here that companies can consider
adopting
the first being a packaging reduction in
terms of the amount of material
the second is on how packaging can be
collected for reuse or recycling
the third is on consumer or industry
outreach related to packaging 3rs
the fourth is the use of recycled
content as part of packaging
and the last is on the improvements in
recyclability or packaging which should
help to make recycling easier
so with the need for waste reduction and
all these measures in place
we do see the importance in encouraging
companies to look into sustainable
packaging now
and for packaging companies to innovate
in tandem to the manufacturers
so by collaborating with our design
singapore council
on the open call platform to connect
designers with companies in the
packaging sector
we hope that this uh platform we hope
that this can
generate more innovative and sustainable
packaging solutions from the
manufacturers that provide essential
services
both locally and also regionally so our
objectives are to create more platforms
for our manufacturing companies such as
our partners today
harvey and s and your group can obtain
more sustainable
packaging solutions through providing
their problem statements
and as the manufacturers evolve their
suppliers will also
need to uh upgrade themselves so we also
hope that the platform can
provide packaging companies for the
supplies to manufacturers
the opportunity to work with designers
to come up with more innovative and
creative ideas
uh to create more value add to their
customers and also offer
more sustainable solutions so uh we have
reached out to the packaging companies
from the packaging council of singapore
and also the print and media association
of singapore to join us today
so for the packaging companies who are
here today if you are keen to be a
resource partner to our designers
please contact us so we can include your
information on the website for the
designers to reach out to you
of course if you have a design team on
your own if you are you are also free to
submit your proposals directly as a
participant
so moving on today's challenge statement
focuses on packaging for the fmv
industry
and the reason why we've targeted fmp as
the first sector to collaborate on
uh it is because of the recent trends
arising from covet 19 that have
generated a greater demand for takeaways
and deliveries
uh fmb operators also see themselves
delivering a wider variety of food
uh times there's a need for more types
of packaging needed for various
forms of food like both hot and cold
ones there's also a need
to ensure there's no cross-contamination
during delivery
and also the need to maintain the
highest standards of hygiene
so the challenge statement for designers
this is
on how you can help our customers by
using innovative processors to design
new and sustainable takeaway packaging
based on their requirements
so their requirements to use sustainable
packaging are similar but
they also they also vary because of the
different types of food that they are
serving
so uh we have worked with the group and
res to provide more details on the
requirements
to uh for this challenge statement and
i'll head over to them to share later
and on this slide i've listed some
packaging concepts that can be explored
some such as smart and multifunctional
designs that minimize materials or
utilize
recycled materials or maybe
specific innovative solutions that can
serve their needs to pack
both hot and cold food you could also
look at optimizing their workflows for
the ease of assembling the packaging
to the actual package uh to actual
packing and delivery of the food
uh minimizing food waste could also be
an area that you can look at
so with that i've come to the end of my
presentation we look forward to your
submissions and once again thank you so
much for joining us today
i shall hand over the stage back to
judea thank you
thank you grace there was a really
insightful presentation and i
completely agree with your point on the
importance to innovate in tandem
for companies like yourself to innovate
in tandem with designers
so um we will now invite winnie senior
marketing manager at rens
to share on how they are pivoting from
using disposable plastic food packaging
to more sustainable ones that can also
contribute to
resolving operational challenges for key
brands such as
ichiban boshi ichiban sushi ichiban
bento
so thank you winnie please thanks judea
and thank you to everyone for taking the
time to be here today to find out more
about
ariana's challenges as well as our
requirements in terms of packaging
design
so before i move on to our problem
statement
i'd first like to give a quick
introduction of rns
and what we do so
rns is a leading restaurant and retail
operator operating japanese restaurants
and various
retail concepts in singapore and
malaysia we were established in 1988
by our chairman hiroshi tatara
today we have 76 fmp outlets
throughout singapore and four outlets in
malaysia
rns may not be a name that's familiar to
a lot of us but i'm sure many of you
have
come into contact with our brands in the
shopping malls on b
ichiban oshi real dining korea japanese
market
or maybe even our bakery gogoku or
our newest concept yakinikubo
our business is divided into two main
segments full service restaurants
and the second segment being quick
service restaurants convenience
and others
so for the purpose of today's discussion
we will be focusing on three
of our core brands ichiban
of which we have 13 outlets throughout
singapore
so this is a full service japanese
restaurant
located in various parts of singapore
the second brand is
ichiban sushi which is a sister brand of
ichiban
oshi currently we have 10 outlets in
singapore
and the third brand is ichiban bento
this is a quick service concept
and it serves some convenient news for
people on the go
so moving on to the problem statement
our key objective at rns is to reduce
our carbon
footprint through evaluating the type
and quantity of material
that is used in our food packaging
so i would first like to share on
ichiban bento
so as you can see from the images this
is a
concept that that
focuses a lot on quick convenient meals
or takeaway
so um the two key offerings or two main
products
that you can see in the picture are
bentos takeaway bentos
which consists of one main item
rice as well as two side dishes maybe
something like a
gyoza and a tamagoyaki the other main
type of product that we have is a
donburi
which is a rice bowl dish so it's kind
of an all-in-one
rice bowl dish customers also
like to order the main items together
with sites like
chawamushi miso soup or an additional
order of site item
like a gyoza or could be a
pocket item
next moving on to ichiban boshi and
ichibang sushi
which are our full service restaurant
brands um here we have two main
product categories on the left
these are essentially coal items
what we call coal items and this
consists mainly of
sushi and sashimi items so the sushi
items could range from
nigiri to gunkan to maki
hand rolls and on the right hand side
we have the second category of hot items
and this could be a simple meal like a
katsukari
so this could be a one dish in itself
or it could be a combination set meal
for example
a hot udon that comes with a side of
tempura
or it could be a grilled fish that could
be accompanied by
your choice of rice miso soup chawamushi
or pickles
so moving on to our challenges when it
comes to packaging
so i think for a lot of fmp players we
see that
during the cb period the circuit breaker
there was a rise
in delivery and takeaway demand and
for us it was um the case as well and
this actually leads to a high usage of
plastic
packaging which are not necessarily the
most eco-friendly
so here are in at rns our top 11 skus
alone contributes to
1.8 million pieces of packaging per year
the second challenge that we have is a
more of a branding
or marketing challenge so we are
currently using off-the-shelf packaging
solutions which
feature generic prints so there's a loss
opportunity for marking
for marketing and a weak brand identity
moving on to the third challenge um this
is operational challenge that we have
so currently we have multiple skus of
different shapes and sizes
so at the store this can be quite messy
and it also takes up
a lot of space and for restaurant
operators
most of us will
empathize that we have very limited
storage space
so so having multiple skus is actually
quite challenging for
us and because of the multiple skus it
can be
easy to miss out orders sometimes
the fourth challenge that we have is a
long delivery time
so when the food is prepared there is
actually a holding time
waiting for the delivery rider or driver
to come to pick it up and during the
delivery process
there's also a waiting time before it
actually arrives
at the consumer's place so because of
this waiting time
the food quality and for safety could
actually be compromised
so in seeking a design solution we have
a few
which list we have a wish list with few
requirements so the first term
is branding so we hope to to find an
eco-friendly solution with
strong branding that can apply across
the three different brands that we
shared earlier
um second consideration very importantly
cost effectiveness
we are looking for a solution that's
competitive with our current
packaging prices so
so that we do not need to pass on the
cost to consumers
and thirdly optimize workflow
so the solution we are looking for
should preferably be stackable
to allow for easy storage we also need
the packaging to be designed in such a
way that it allows us to
check the pack orders easily so this
could be the form
of transparent plastic leads or
otherwise we are also looking at
minimizing the skus that we have today
and importantly the packaging has to be
leak proof
[Music]
the last point that we have temperature
maintenance
so because of the two types of food that
i shared earlier
we are this is important for us that the
coal or raw food items have to be
maintained at a temperature below 20
degrees celsius
and for the hot items at a temperature
above 60 degrees celsius
and lastly we are hoping to tackle the
creativity of our designers
to provide some creative solutions
that can possibly allow us to pack both
the hot
and cold items in the same bag maybe
through
insulation or other solutions
[Music]
so with that one more point
this is a good to have feature user
friendliness
so if the packaging has elements like a
microwavable
or attachment for calories that would be
something that would be nice to have as
well
so with that i had the time back to
julia thank you
thank you winnie it's a really engaging
presentation and i like how you got us
to think about the whole ecosystem of
packaging from branding to operations to
even how
the food how hot or cold the food is
after delivery right
it's just really important to consider
as designers so
with that we will now invite tl
assistant director
of sales at new group limited to share
more on how they would like to work with
designers on new designs
for sustainable food packaging that can
retain heat well
to replace the use of plastic bento
boxes and by gas bento boxes
so with that thank you and i'll give
pass the time over to you
thank you thank you julia good day
everyone
first and foremost uh let me introduce
our group to everyone
new grow is singapore's integrated food
solution provider
backed by a strong track record to
accumulate over 28 years
listed on sjx since july 2012
new group provides customers with
end-to-end food catering solutions
through a comprehensive suite of
capabilities
service offerings under four main
business segments
we have catering manufacturing supplies
and trading
and food retail our strong value
proposition
and strong commitments to constantly
innovate and remain at the forefront
of cutting-edge technologies has enabled
us to solidify our position as
singapore's number one
event caterer
financial year 2020 revenue is the new
record for the group
reaching 185.9 million mainly driven by
food catering business as the group
continues to grow recurring incomes and
ad
income streams from different brands
this is the future of new group coming
quarter for
2021 we will be unveiling our new
facility at 30b
quality road a massive 270 2 000 square
feet property that will house a fully
automated
state-of-the-art central kitchen this
progressive facility will also unveil
first of its kind customized machineries
that will automate many of our
signature dishes and important functions
new group oversees an expanding
portfolio of 20 brands in which
includes
catering covering the entire spectrum of
the catering markets through our white
offerings of quality food and buffets
under our strong portfolio of brands
include new garden
orange cloth deli heart lavish dine
manufacturing our second largest revenue
driver
tonsil global and many of you will know
this homegrown brand
dodo fishball
for supplies and trading nkk
import and export and high q global they
are handling new groups
bulk supplies from other countries city
vegetables
and er marketing that are supplying
fruits vegetables and meat
for food retail the group now owns a
food retail network spending more than
20 outlets
island white umi sushi and iso izakaya
bring you japanese cuisine juche kimchi
singapore's number one rice dumping
brand
our group's initiative on zero waste
management
new groups launched our zero waste
initiative in early 2019
with a purpose to raise awareness
educate
review internal process research and
develop methods
internally collectors are being posted
to staff
teachers on kitchen logistics boards and
for don'ts with no access to work desk
educate we have adopted numerous
initiatives to educate internal external
stakeholders to be more environmentally
conscious in their daily activities
we are the first caterer to adopt
biodegradable ware since 2010
on top of setting the trend we also
implemented measures to prevent wasteful
usage such as cut down on over supplies
and educate customers to use one cell
utensil through the buffet
switch to paper cups they are coated
with pla providing reusable containers
and warmer bags at no cost to customers
all new group soviets are manufactured
using forest stewardship causer
fsc certified paper which is 100
recyclable
using only one color print
providing porcelain wears and more table
was options
and reviewing our own internal process
to reduce carbon footprint
we implemented e-invoicing and automated
the process as well
clients will receive their invoice upon
acknowledging the receipt of their
orders or none
on our mobile devices
going digital we are promoting
e-brochures menu online
encouraging customers to place online
orders through our websites
marketing product offerings on social
medias channels to reach out to
consumers
other green initiatives within the
organization such as
no econ day off lights during lunch time
minimize printing of dish tags
digitalize
internal process of having this shaft
cures
menu board to reduce paper usage
okay here we are sharing some pictures
of more commonly used bento box
[Music]
single compartment three compartments
four compartments
these are made of pp materials which are
very common in the market now
affordable lower cost than bhagas
where we do not need to pass the cost to
our customers
orange clothes started to introduce
bagans and bamboo parkware into our
menus from july 2020 we saw
a shift in demand from top corporate
customers
that prefer to support sustainability as
well during
covet let me share our challenge
statements
with the increase in demand for catering
bento sets during covet 19 pandemic
how might we design sustainable food
packaging used for these food caterings
as there is a high demand from top
corporate companies supporting
sustainability
newly designed sustainable food
packaging will replace the use of
plastic bento boxes and bagasse bento
boxes
while baga's vendor boxes are
comparative more sustainable than
plastic bento boxes
they do not retain heat well
as you all can see here are the numbers
of our bento orders
before kovic and during covig
there was a search in bento orders
especially during the circuit breaker
period
delhi hub saw a 164
growth due to bento meals catered to
dormitories starting from late march to
august
to further to further add on we see an
urgent need to find sustainable solution
due to the high plastic waste generated
for instance trending now if anyone have
tried
don't hide the alarm self-hitting
steamboats or high secure
recently local caterers are adopting
these boxes to bring convenient to
consumer
their selling point is very on heating
up the food
and guests get to eat hot food but as
you can see from the video
the amount of plastic waste generated
from this packaging is not little
a requirement so we are looking for
design photo types of sustainable food
packaging that is
able to retain the temperature of cooked
food meet food safety requirement for
single use
consumer effect cost effective so that
costs will not be passed on to consumers
stackable and aesthetically pleasing
i hope i have given you a good summary
of who new group is and we are
very excited to receive your application
thank you thank you tr tan
i actually had one of those self-heating
mala things and i
was laughing when you were showing that
picture because there was really a lot
of plastic
quite bizarre but it i mean fascinating
to
to experience i guess but thank you for
that insightful presentation um it's
heartening to know that your group has
already
been taking small steps to adopt
different
sustainable packaging in your
sustainable approaches in your packaging
so now that our our challenge statement
providers have shared about the
challenges in their industry
if you have any other questions about
the presentation please submit them
through the q
a module below as we will be moving on
to the next segment
right now which is the q a so there have
already been several
questions streaming through the chat
that i'm looking at
um but keep them coming and we'll
definitely try to address them if we can
so can i just invite um weenie as well
to join us for the q a session and the
other speakers too
all right so i think one of the
questions that
has come in this one can be
opened up to any of you two to respond
to um it's quite interesting
do you guys have any thoughts on
tackling the take out culture
as opposed to designing solutions for
sustainable takeout
so i guess it's taking a step back and
addressing the
the culture of taking away instead
maybe i can start the board and thank
you maybe the other
speakers can add on i i think a
long-term solution
has to address multiple stakeholders
um so education of consumers is one
thing but engaging
vendors engaging operators like
ourselves
it's also very important so while
meeting the needs of the business
i think um business operators play a big
part
because of the share volume that we are
producing
so so i think um it's not that easy um
there's no easy answers
but i think it's a long term process
that all of us are
involved in yeah definitely it's a very
complex issues that has
um plenty of moving parts so um
that we that there's an opportunity to
definitely look into
how about um tl or or we need your thing
oh sorry not really is there anything to
add with
i guess for sorry for singapore
i think we are fast paced and many a
time
you know we are there are a lot of
working adults that is taking away
taking out food instead so of course we
will need time to
you know educate everyone the users to
start you know to bring their own
boxes as well but though we definitely
need a
solution right now to
curb the amount of you know plastic
waste that we are using
[Music]
for a future it's a pressing problem as
well
i think both the takeaway culture and um
and the take away material or the
innovation in that
space as well um thank you thank you for
that
um ways just to check if you have
anything else
yeah i absolutely agree i think
while we try to change cultures but i
think
i mean package take away i mean it will
still be part of our lives
there's still definitely a need for it
so i think the focus of today's
uh challenge statement would still be to
actually solve this issue
yeah i mean if it is still going to be
necessary then
yeah it will be how we can actually make
it better to make it more sustainable
so i think that's what we are hoping to
depend on the designer song for
yeah so hope that we can find some
uh interesting things hopefully the
designers tuning in to the um
understand the challenges of our
different fmv providers a bit better
to see how they can potentially respond
because it's definitely a pressing
challenges that we offer especially in
singapore particularly culture is strong
right
but i think with this you can move on to
the next question um
which is quite interesting as well so
this person asked
if sorry let me just grab it
um yeah what are packaging for drinks so
most of you have presented um
that you would like to address packaging
solutions for bento boxers or for food
items
have you guys ever explored sustainable
packaging
solutions for drinks instead well for
arien there's some
i think um drinks so we we do not
um sell a lot of drinks
i mean of course we do sell drinks as
part of our meals but
meals are still essentially the majority
when it comes to takeout and delivery
items
so so for us i think our priority is to
focus on the takeaway packaging with
regards to news
from start so i think that will have
greater impact
yeah so i guess um i guess food items is
the bigger contributor
in the organization right
i mean the same goes for us before this
we were i think
before kobe we're allowed to do buffet
so of course there's a lot of drinks
involved and paper cups
and with this restriction now that you
know we can only cater to bentos or
these
drinks is not really like in demand now
and
i think i mean this and we do not
manufacture drink as well so
many times i think for this we have to
definitely leave it to the drinks
manufacturers to see i mean what can
they actually offer us in time to come
thanks for sharing that um with that i
think there's a question actually
directed at your group
so here you can respond to this someone
asked if there's actually an opportunity
for you to work with students from
universities and colleges outside of
singapore
for this i mean definitely there's
opportunity
and uh i mean because this project
currently now we are actually
working together with psg and jtc so i
mean we have to
definitely look at you know application
as well
yeah we will definitely review it
so yeah those two those tuning in who
may be outside of singapore
um there are potential for
collaborations with your group
maybe possibly outside of this current
color fitness
or the gdr-initiated um
so um i think one more question
that is directed to our ems and your
group has your organization
considered partnering with companies
that offer reusables
so these could be companies like news or
webhack
to see how they can be implemented on a
larger scale as opposed to against
designing something
maybe i can take that question first um
i understand backpack is like a
recyclable bento box
and um i mean i don't know how their
business model works but
uh i mean we did have clients looking i
mean
that cater daily mails you know
currently they are actually
using pp plastics and they are looking
at a few hundred people each day but
we did consider like having
no reusable bento boxes for their own
workers because
those that's convincing consuming the
meals are actually
fake people they are workers but the
concern came
right you know to us is you know hygiene
the handling like you know after they
eat the meal
the washing part and then you know when
they pass back the boxes to us for us to
pack you know
they are concerned that there may be
contamination i see
yeah but of course you know if moving
forward if let's say there's no
definite changes to work with males or
backpacks you know we definitely will
look at it
thank you um we need you have something
to add to that
i think we are open to exploring the
possibilities or the options
um at this point in time i can't say we
have
started anything actively but we are
openly open to exploring any kind of
partnerships i guess this leads to a
related question
that has come in someone asked how
feasible do business operators like
yourself think about
i think encouraging patrons to return
packaging for using
how feasible that is so i guess um you
actually responded to that earlier
regarding the the cleanliness or the
potential contamination of it
is that the key deterrence factor
to approaching this returning system
[Music]
definitely is a key factor because uh we
do not want to see
you know like people running the loo
going to you know
nea start checking us because whenever
and i think in singapore cases like this
is taken in
very seriously so i mean to protect
everybody's health interests i guess you
know
hygiene is definitely a very very
important part for food
yeah i agree with that
i think for rns our biggest um and
foremost
concern and priority has always and will
always be food safety
so food hygiene and food safety is very
very important to us
so to to reuse some
packaging especially those that are
designed for single use i think would
have some
major concerns for us
i see um yeah i think we definitely
understand that limitation and we will
have to take that into consideration
when designing a solution in response to
the challenges
um i think the next question can be
um maybe grace you could answer these as
well um
how much cost would businesses like
yours actually be comfortable to absorb
if proposed sustainable solutions for
the cost more
so i think of course maybe the company
scale will be in a better position to
answer
yeah maybe like yeah mini or tl can take
the question
thanks
this is something that is um it's a very
key
limitation that you are working as well
or you're actually open to
i guess investing more
um how much cost in terms of um
dollars and cents of course you know
it's not anything more than
i mean we definitely do not wish to put
the cost back to consumers but
um it's definitely no more than actually
a dollar for us
[Music]
that's a helpful benchmark for our
listeners
um how about you me i think it's hard to
put a number to
it it really depends on what kind of
solution you're talking about so so we
we can't just um
look at it as very simplistic um
replacing what we are doing today with
another like
um product um
with just a different material maybe but
um
we have to consider other aspects as
well so
yeah so i wouldn't really put a number
to it but of course i think
it cannot be triple what we are
um currently paying or packaging because
then um it wouldn't be sustainable for
our business
and you know that would then lead to an
adjustment of selling price
so at the end of the day i think we have
to consider um all aspects
yeah i think sustainability of the
solution is definitely a key factor as
well
yes um but maybe i would also like to
add on that
we also do recognize that changing the
packaging
or exploring something that's more
eco-friendly inevitably
results in a rising cost in many cases
so that's something that we already
prepared for
when we embark on this initiative
definitely yeah um one more question
that has come
in is
um
i guess this is something um with
regards to comparing
what's in what you guys have done with
other countries
so what regarding reducing packaging
waste do you guys have
any ideas of what have worked in other
countries and why it
might not work in singapore would or
would not work
maybe it's about contextualizing these
solutions that people have explored
yeah i think in terms of packaging
if i'm not wrong i feel what i think for
singapore is that um
i think singaporeans they are not very
aware of what kind of
packaging can be recycled and what kind
there are some that are like
full contaminated uh packaging that
actually can't be recycled anymore
that's what i understand
yeah and um i think uh segregating of
waste as well different kinds of
recyclable waste
yeah maybe uh what i thought was
to actually properly label such
packaging so that it's easier for
consumers to know how to do recycling
yeah that would be a key difference that
you know because i i do know that there
are some countries which
have very very high uh uh
percentage of recycling done yeah but i
think a lot of that
has to do with the knowledge of how to
do so
yeah so uh if there are changes in the
type of
ways to educate consumers on how to do
recycling i think that will really help
so um currently if i'm wrong but what
you're saying is it's also a systemic
issue
um of how recycling the the whole
i guess ecosystem of recycling is set up
in singapore and how
aware our consumers are in what they
cannot do
yeah but i think it's changing with uh
nea coming up with the
mandatory magazine reporting and i think
yeah it means kind of pushing companies
to really look in
uh into packaging and to see how uh how
to better
uh create packaging that that is more
easily recycled and
how i mean i think companies will also
have to take back
the packaging to ensure that uh there's
less waste being
produced i think there is a step that
andy is thinking
yeah yeah i agree with you on that point
so i'll take one more question before we
move on to
before we move on to the clothing so
must we also design
for the bento boxes to be recycled after
use or do we assume that these ventral
boxes
will be disposed without recycling maybe
i can take this first step
can add on um so essentially we are
looking at a single use um
solution so so i would say
um something that's disposable is what
we are looking
at at this point in time in the future
we may consider recyclables but i think
that's maybe
a little further down the road for us at
this point in time
it's it's helpful to know that it's in
consideration
further down the pipeline i guess how
about tl
um i mean same as what uh winnie has
mentioned
we are looking for single use and long
run
of course if you can actually help to
recycle that single use
um you know we would definitely be very
glad to
do our part so to the design potential
designer who asked that question
um there's definitely potential in
designing
for to be recycled um and
and i guess it's worth pushing for that
as well so thank you
thank you very much our panelists today
for this engaging conversation
and for those of you who are keen on
designing for impact projects
and are seeking for inspirations for
suitable project partners
we hope that this webinar so far has
inspired you to design for
sustainability and for our future and if
you are keen to continue exploring
design research projects
and respond to their children statements
please reach out to us for more
information
and you may also participate in our next
good design research open call
that is gonna launch in mid april and
with this
uh my colleague me will be sharing more
about the next gpr open call
thank you thanks judia so um for all of
you
thank you for joining us in this session
uh if you are keen to learn more about
the good design research challenge
statements and draw inspiration
from the existing challenge statements
that we have or you may scan the qr code
that you see on the screen right now
so as julia has mentioned you know if
you are a designer or
design enterprise and are keen to
respond to rens as well as new groups
challenge statement or any other
challenge statement actually on our
website
please do participate in our next gdr
open call
that will be launching mid-april like i
have shared earlier on you will stand a
chance to receive cash sponsorship
mentorship and publicity support for
your proposal
so maybe to bring everything together uh
our applicants that we are looking for
it will be
the designers as well as the design
enterprises and then for
new group as well as rens those are
potential um
i guess i mean potential clients in the
future you know if you have a strong
solution
to propose uh and then for the packaging
companies that are that are present in
this session
they could also partner with our
designers as well as the design
enterprises in terms of then
you know coming up with this kind of new
innovative prototypes that
you know you can you can you can submit
for a proposal
for our open call yeah so for our open
call
uh like i said we will be launching it
mid april and then
a week after we will also have an open
call briefing session
uh during the session it will be focused
on an interactive q a session
with the gdr evaluation panel members
as well as some of the past supported
designers so that you can gain more
insight into what
you know we are looking for in a strong
proposal
so we look forward to receiving your
submissions and the next year open call
and you know if you have any queries uh
or questions you know we will be
sharing a follow-up email after this
session and then you could also
uh reach out to us if you have any
queries thank you so much wendy
all right so we we hope you found this
session inspiring and meaningful
hearing from the fmb providers
themselves and once again we would like
to thank you for joining us this
afternoon
and our speakers as well for the really
insightful sharing
as a follow-up from this webinar we will
be sharing a summary of the session
along with the contact details of the
speakers after this session
so you can also scan the qr code on the
slide for more details on a good design
research initiative
as well as the challenge statements
including those from our knowledge
partners today like ie and s
and your group and other other open
challenge statements as well sorry so um
with that we come to an
end and we hope to see you at our
subsequent events or even your
submissions through the upcoming
gdr open call thank you and see you
[Music]
again